[Music]
Senator Brown thank you so much for
joining us I'm going to jump right in
inflation is at a 40-year record high
who is responsible for fixing it the fed
or the government the government clearly
caused it in this case
some of it a little bipartisan and that
the uncertainty of covid we did a four
trillion dollar package and you can't
shut the supply side down which we did
as a government and then just throw all
that purchasing power into a constrained
economy that's instant inflation I
wonder if the small business owners in
Indiana did benefit from stimulus from
PPP loans and how you square that with
it's kind of like bragging about the gas
prices coming down when you did
everything policy wise to cause it in
the first place yes a small business had
to be thrown a Lifeline because
government shut them down but you got to
remember those businesses wouldn't have
needed the PPP program we wouldn't have
needed extended unemployment benefits if
we had just done it a little differently
what is a single policy move that could
be made to help consumers who are
struggling today quit digging the hole
deeper for giving 400 billion dollars
worth of student debt that was a really
questionable policy move and then the
passing a bill that you had the gall to
call the inflation reduction act it's
not a good business plan uh you know for
the country and we're the second most
indebted major economy in the world next
to Japan
about the impact of all this on the
midterms inflation is the pretty number
one issue issue nationally for voters
right up there number two is abortion to
what extent are you concerned about how
Republicans will perform in November
given the pullback in abortion access
well let's look at November which I'll
get to in a second and that's been
litigated so much because it's so
imminent I'm worried about Republicans
in terms of what we do in the long run
we can't be the party of nowhere I'm not
interested we got to be a party that has
a business plan for the country so
Republicans have got a lot of
opportunity neither party in my opinion
is given the American public a plan that
you should be confident in because we
haven't gotten there yet but we do
continue to report on stories of Life
Republican voters who are now switching
their votes due to the reversal of Roe
are you concerned about that and I think
you're going to find some life Democrats
that have been in places where their
cities aren't the same as many of them
have become Republicans you can always
have your cultural issues I was happy
when it just went to the states
I think that's where it probably needs
to be litigated anyway on things that we
can't agree with I've got my views on
all the cultural issues but a little
libertarian in nature and I think much
of the younger generation is that way
too
but on the other hand we don't want
government in our economic business as
well to the extent it is because it has
not done well for the economy you sound
like someone who might be running for
governor at some point do you care to
break some news for us today here I
think I could do a few things as
Governor here I'm mostly talking about
it right well I'll take that then thank
you so much Senator really appreciate
your time thank you you're welcome
[Music]